earlier today Senator Lindsey Graham
issued a statement read quote after
today's hearing and for the good of the
country I hope this is the end of the
Muller report now we it's time to find
out how this debacle started and went so
far
senator Graham joins us now your
question I always go back to you asked
Ernie general Barr you confident Muller
had everything he needed to get the job
done at a time
no president never invoked executive
privilege once well I don't want and I
have million documents everybody was
accessible my question is does Hillary
get away with a fixed investigation when
she committed crimes to the people
involved in lying to a FISA Court
consciously do they get away with it
that people that tried to influence a
presidential election get away with it
and people that tried to undo that
election get away with it senator or
you've got to make sure that doesn't
happen I'm more determined today after
this hearing to get to the bottom of it
the question did Hillary get led off
because the people investigating her
wanted her to win and Trump to lose was
the reason that she wasn't prosecuted
it's because of a political decision
political motivations all the things are
very important the one thing I can tell
you after today the Muller report is in
name only
and the idea that you say that's a good
report we'll see but it clearly wasn't
the Muller report it's just a name I had
more to do with the Mulder report than
probably he did and you know what
bothers me a lot people around Bob
Muller knew he was in a weakened state
this guy served in Vietnam got wounded
done a lot of great things for the
country he should not have been called
senator let me let me agree with you
you know when the Attorney General
agreed to the joint statement Attorney
General I said at the time he did the
favor to bob Muller the Attorney General
was warning this is going to be a
spectacle seems like the only person
that understood and tried to prevent it
was the one that was being accused of
trying to rig it was the Attorney
General knew that this would be a
disaster for Muller and you're right his
background is one of a hero they the
people that allowed this that used
him the politicians on that committee
and the people on that yeah on that
group that hired and did all this and he
knew nothing and ran the show without
him they're the ones that did this to
his reputation
the Bentley the hatred for Trump knows
no boundaries they use this this man and
one of the reasons I told people early
on I was not going to call Muller's
because the report speaks for itself but
I was told by people close to Bob Miller
that he really shouldn't have to go
through this they knew he wasn't capable
of this I am a stupid talk-show host I
was told repeatedly he's not up to the
task well here's the point I've been
asked for three months why don't you
want to call Muller I bet you nobody
will ask me that tomorrow I was a letter
was sent to me by every Democrat on the
Judiciary Committee in the Senate why
don't you call Muller nobody's going to
ask me that tomorrow here's where n say
Donald Trump is stronger tonight than
any time in his presidency that need to
find out what happened is greater today
than it was before is clear that Bob
Muller was not in charge of
investigation and like every American
who cares about the rule of law we need
to find out how this started senator but
on so long we need the senator Graham
that changed the course of the Cavanaugh
hearing to take control of this your
country needs you this is important this
republic came dangerously close to
allowing lies and conspiracy theories
few powerful people unseat a duly
elected president we need your country
needs you that's just the fact well
they're their time is coming the
president's gone through hill for two
and a half years and nobody else could
have taken it but him I know today I
don't see they're trying to ruin his
family's life and he's tough as nails
but those who who engaged in the FISA
Court abuse and I think fraud this their
time and the only way you'll ever stop
this in the future is to make people
your committee it's going to be a
crucial senator we I know you will I
believe you thank you for you two going
to do to get to the truth